petrograd in march 1917 scene of the end
of the reign of the Romanovs in february
when workers and soldiers rose against his
artists nicholas ii abdicated in favor of
his brother Michael who refused the throne
and the provisional government was headed
by a social revolutionary Alexander Kerensky
Russia went wild this was the new Soviet this
the intermediary step which brought Nikolai Lenin
into prominence and boosted Bolshevism into power
current speed war policies met with opposition
and aroused populist demanded still more changes
Masek speakers meringue cloud's calling
for immediate action calling for Bolshevik
members of the Soviet to refuse to back the
provisional government Lanyon arrived from
Switzerland sponsored by the Germany that hoped
to see him lead Russia into a separate peace
80,000 Bolshevik Party members came out into
the open du Bac Lenin and his co-leader Leon
Trotsky associated in the party as general
secretary is the man who was to direct the
destinies of Russia this was Joseph Stalin in
1917 in an effort to negate the influence of
Lenin Trotsky and Bolshevism Kerensky called
a meeting of the all-russian conference at the
Bolshoi Theatre in Moscow delegate against Jeff
and others third Kerensky declared that Lenin
had inspired organized anti-war propaganda for
the time being Kerensky won his point but on
November 17th 1917 the Bolsheviks rose in riot
armed mob stormed the Winter Palace speaking
Kerensky who fled months of preparation will
culminated in this dramatic climax to Venom's
revolution Moscow had already fallen these actual
scenes in petrograd and these filmed in Moscow
after had fallen to the Reds mark the historic
advent into power of the Bolsheviks Lenin had
returned later in October from Finland to take
over Petrograd was to be renamed Leningrad in
his honor Xena fierce fighting was the Kremlin
which shows the marks of riflemen artillery fire
a red flag flies over